all right welcome everybody we have
quite a day uh on the agenda today
welcome to everybody joining me we are
starting even earlier than i planned
because
things are already getting a little
wacky at the capitol so i'm gonna set
the stage for everybody momentarily um
but there have already been a couple of
altercations we're gonna see if we can
go back
uh in this stream and show them to you
uh but a lot of really crazy things
happening and upcoming so let me see if
i can sort of set the stage for people
today is the day of
what is being called the justice for j6
rally in washington dc
now we hope that there will be no riot
of course and
because of that we even have a code
please know riot that's the code today
on my website please know riot just like
that and you have to say it like that
when you type it in please no riot guys
it's like please clap sir
um
the this rally is in support of
the rioters from january 6th so there's
a contingent of trump's trump trumpians
who
think that
we need to be defending the january 6th
rioters they're being treated too
harshly by the justice system they feel
so they have come out today
in support of the rioters now hopefully
they won't riot and dc is very well
protected as you're going to see so far
this is the only stream i found this is
a channel called
news to share and i think it's just this
guy's streaming this is the only thing
i've found so far let's take a brief
listen um
so far pretty uh
relatively small i mean it's hard to
estimate because they're spread around
the crowd but like
um this this will sound like i'm
exaggerating because of how big the
crowd of like journalists is but like i
think it's only like roughly 30 or
um so my god it's mostly journalists
anyway so we're watching this and um we
we you know the dc is very well prepared
they've bolstered security they've done
a lot of different things and it seems
very unlikely that things are going to
get uh too too out of control today okay
so so that's what we're standing by and
watching here uh now i will of course
take super chats i see michael grill
grilly says thanks for streaming this
hashtag please know riot i appreciate
that yes we're going to be watching all
of these things very very closely and
i'm so glad that people are here and
that people are joining me but but we
hope that there will be no riot there
were
these two guys who i don't know if these
guys are supposed to be security or what
they are they just showed up and they're
looking very very strong as you can tell
but i want to go back to show you guys
there was a moment where there was a
pretty unhinged woman
who made a declaration here it is and at
one point some some kind of authorities
even showed up let's see if we can
listen to it i know the volume's low i'm
gonna try to boost it okay stand by
let's see if i can do that
cuatro
you can really not even hear the
altercation
yeah this same woman was ranting before
uh here we go
[Music]
so it seemed capital police was
particularly suspicious of this woman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know what to do in life
anymore i don't know what to do
what are we to do
huh
shameful
[ __ ] rich people are sitting up there
[Music]
i'm going to get away from that she
i don't know i see the comments she may
have cerebral palsy i'm not sure and i
don't know i don't know
i don't know what's going on with that
it's a mental health issue or could be
neurological i don't know all right
let's get back to what's going on as you
can see the crowd is starting to build a
little bit
here okay so anyway we're monitoring
this and the the formality the formal
event is meant to start at the top of
the hour and we're going to be
continuing to um we're going to be
continuing to watch that of course
really really closely um 56 landon says
via super chat what about state capitals
in red and purple states i'm not aware
of any events at state capitals if you
guys are you can let me know and we can
we can look look at that but i'm not i'm
not aware of anything like that going on
today
um also if people are aware of other
streams this is a pretty good stream
it's long it's wide it's really all the
things that we would want i'm keeping an
eye
on other possible streams
here's one that is one of these like
nine boxes and some of these elements
don't seem at all relevant to us like
for example the lower right seems to be
an extremely zoomed out just map of the
area i don't know what that tells us for
example down here
but
um newsmax not surprisingly is not
covering this but we will monitor the
news max feed and then news 4 was
supposedly covering the j6 rally see it
says here but they scheduled it for last
night
it's all very strange
zack petrizzo
is on the ground so we're going to
monitor the things that he has
let's look at his thread currently on
the ground in the nation's capital for
the justice for j6 rally robust police
presence in addition to plenty of dump
trucks are on the scene big dump trucks
more police on the scene than pro-trump
rally-goers as of now
two guys with far-right three-percenter
flags rolled through
make sure you get b-roll footage of the
crowd a cameraman jokes to a large crowd
of journalists one problem there are
close to zero rally goers that was 46
minutes ago so it seems that there are a
few more people
showing up here um and the we are still
30 minutes 28 minutes from the official
start of the event so we'll see what
happens but already a couple of
minor altercations uh capitol police
coming out to talk to some specific
folks who seem to be
really
more in mental health crisis than
rioting at this point in time
but in any case if you're just joining
us we don't want a riot
okay and just to remind everybody how
much we don't want a riot you'll see
that today's coupon code is please no
riot
please no riot that's all one word all
lowercase you can use that to sign up at
joinpakman.com if you want to support
the rare weekend stream or whatever you
guys want to do we do have that
available uh i do want to say a big
thank you to our friend lars berenroth
who um streams under the handle deeper
shades of house who just gifted five
subs today really appreciate that also
thanks to chaotic stasis jen here has
gifted two and that already puts us at
eight but we do have
that code please know riot and that
works at joinpakman.com i can assure you
folks it works i've tested it
extensively
um
i did have i had my coffee this morning
i did in fact i put a picture up
uh this was a really really strong cup
of coffee you can see my name spelled
correctly on the cup here david
and our good friend josh perry who we
continue to uh you know wish the best in
his recovery from his from brain surgery
josh perry coming in sir
very very strong
um so everybody chiming in there
um
my bagel is gone it's all it's all
happening i did oh by the way i got my
hair fixed as well i know a lot of
people were very concerned that i got a
bad haircut and i did i got a very very
bad haircut the other day but i got it
fixed yesterday okay
so it's all fixed
uh david this is like a fever dream god
help us yeah i know
john mccormick coming in with a 500 what
what does anybody know what currency is
this this is it's like a p with three
lines through it i've never seen that
before
um i think orange means it's roughly 20
bucks but i appreciate that
um br madden says david is it true you
have magical powers it is
radical liberal raphael warnock says i
just got power and internet back after
hurricane ida this is the first stream
i've been able to catch enjoy your
channel glad to be back glad to have you
back
um
[Music]
sir man dude guy says they are trying
really hard to cope they can't take the
l i know
and john doe says i saw people on parlor
and the great and great awakening saying
protest at local capitals instead of dc
if anything happens in dc it's a false
flag false flag well
that is something
that is something if that is the case we
will monitor it all closely
thanks to elon musk for raiding us with
a party of one always uh very interested
in all raids let's take a listen to the
sights and sounds at the rally in
support of the trump rioters
let's hope there will be no riot
and you can use the code please know
riot to get an immorally big discount at
joinpakman.com
so it's all relatively calm right now
if anybody does have
suggestions for additional streams that
we should be looking at let me know
because um
this is just one stream this looks sort
of like low rent secret service that
they have
ready
like is is there something a little bit
kind of k fabe about this are these guys
larping this looks like a very low rent
security you know these guys in the
suits over here um
it's really the attendees are mostly
journalists and security it's kind of
interesting
yeah it's kind of like bootleg secret
service exactly
the crowd does seem to be building
from the standpoint of people
three weeks ago i feel like yeah we come
and go
all right good i like this stream this
is um once again this is a
streamer named news to share
relatively small channel 55 000
subscribers we really appreciate this
stream this is the only reliable stream
i've been able to find from the event
we're monitoring a couple of other
streams as you can see here many of them
are completely useless newsmax still not
covering it and news 4 nashville
continuing not to cover it let's see if
there's any other justice for j6
streams
u.s capital
oh let's see this may be another one
let's see
as many streams as we can find the
better
let's mute this one and then check this
one out here
ah very good we have another stream now
excellent okay good so we're building
we're building our uh our arsenal here
um
this is just a compilation of feeds okay
good all right so we've added a second
stream
good all right i'm comfortable with this
i'm glad that uh that we have this i
wanna say a huge thank you to john
atkins john just signed up on my website
using the coupon code please know riot
and his new member number nine today we
don't want a riot uh contrary to what
like don jr or anybody might be saying
we we want things to be calm i just want
this to completely flop that's really my
desire
um but just as a reminder
because
we are here uh
not wanting a riot the code is please
know riot if you've been thinking of
signing up on my website today's a great
day to do it and the code please know
riot
what that code does shouldn't even be
legal so i'm not gonna say more people
wondering when this quote starts that's
a vague term when it starts but i think
the the speeches are scheduled for noon
eastern which is just 21 minutes from
now and how long this is go on i don't
know
um let's see other super chats coming in
what number number machine will go for 2
trillion
what number machine will go for like 2
trillion i'm not sure i know what that
means
chaka seki says hey david where is
liberal cluck i know liberal cluck
should be here streaming jordan ewell
from tyt will be on scene streaming
uh okay let's see jordan ewell
not getting any results for jordan ewell
but we'll keep looking
uh boston boy says you're awesome dave
let's hope for no violence
john mccormick with another 125. i guess
i'm being told those are phil that's the
filipino currency
switch mitch says excited to see that
you and dylan burns will be having a
conversation yes i'm scheduled to uh
co-stream it'll be a joint stream with
dylan burns i think it's wednesday
evening
so that'll be really great i hope people
will be joining us adam checking in says
david sir good morning from jacksonville
florida much love from brittany and adam
thanks guys
ironically i'm currently disassembling
my lego statue of liberty set to put it
back together while watching the stream
is that a bad omen should i stop yeah
yeah
sorry i meant joe manchin joe manchin is
going to be streaming
what is the point of airing this rally
when does it become a platform to those
intent on destroying democracy that this
is this is i mean look this is a
referendum on are these people going to
continue bringing violence to dc or have
have they been totally deflated i find
it newsworthy uh i'm i would be
following this
uh regardless so i i'm streaming it
because i would be watching it myself
and why not
um i wanna say a big thank you to weston
gettings who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code please know
riot
that's today's code
also thanks to your mom's friend as well
as donna downey and m guinea for signing
up via twitch appreciate that this is
officially starting at the top of the
hour we're monitoring two feeds let's
take a quick listen
okay so not much happening there let's
see this is another boots on the ground
stream
there was also i'll show you guys on the
on the highlight video later there's a
guy with an electric guitar and he was
like rocking out like some uh
some justice for j6 rock tunes on
electric guitar
so
arsenal's leading burnley that's good
news okay so i guess they're doing some
soccer soccer scores at this point so
we're gonna keep watching it i know the
volume is low i've i've boosted it as
much as i can unfortunately on my end
um and i don't know how much more i can
do as far as that goes
uh oh you know what i might be able to
do hold on let me see let me see if i
can just get uh let's see um
volume master
let me add volume master to see
oh it's i have it installed hold on a
second i thought i did yeah
let's see if i can why is it not visible
um
i have the volume master extension and
for some reason
it's not actually showing up
let's see if i remove it and then add it
again
ah there we go
okay
all right so let's see if now
that'll get us some more volume here
let's let's test it
uh we'll go over here
now we just lost the stream
let's try this one four news crews out
here
now i will tell you that i rode my i
rode the bike all the way up capitol
hill and around it's a little bit better
i hope we didn't lose this feat i hope
the streamer didn't lose uh
ah there we go
i think that's better
i think when there's something to
actually listen to it's going to be much
much louder there so i i think that
that's good good good idea there guys
uh uh oh
now the stream has ended
oh no did they get shut down do you guys
think they got shut down
because now this is back to the
beginning
um that's not good hopefully they
restart their stream let's stand by uh
we do have this other feed for the time
being so we'll keep an eye on that
hopefully news to share gets going again
what is this middle feed i wonder
because that one might be useful for us
uh
yeah i'm not seeing
all right we're gonna keep watching
hopefully news to share restarts their
stream i don't know if they even know
their stream has been shut down
very good all right we're standing by i
want to say thanks to landon tanieri for
signing up on my website with the code
please know riot also thanks to blaine
o'kelly for the membership jose
guevarola
aldrin ah
and jonathan fest have all just signed
up putting us at 18.
uh appreciate that also thanks over on
twitch to check tour as well as lots of
jello who just gifted five subs
that's six putting us at 24.
i very much appreciate that let me read
a couple of other super chats here
um
[Music]
where did we start here okay his name is
hassan okay have you been following the
inspiration for civilian space mission i
have not
does anything make you more depressed
than a barista that doesn't know a
cortado is four ounces yeah i mean you
know sometimes you go places they're
giving you 16 ounce cappuccinos they're
giving you 12 ounce cortados it
shouldn't even be legal should not even
be legal
david is the u.s healthcare system
broken in your mind it's quite broken
yeah
should we be afraid of a my pillow fight
absolutely
p with three lines is the philippine
peso thank you
david sir what's the deal with the us's
almost fanatical obsession with
individualism at the expense of social
welfare we've discussed that a lot the
u.s is sort of unique in that sense oh
let's something's going on let's see
that will spice it up that's a direct
quote from this event
let's see if news news to share seems to
have been pulled this was the best
stream it seems to have been pulled
completely offline
we still have the
penguin six stream
and then we have this multi-stream
newsmax pretending this isn't going on i
think this stream we can close out
um
yep
if anybody else is aware let's just do
another search to see if there are other
streams we'll filter for live of course
um
this seems to be a new stream
coming online let's listen to video
you ready doc
hmm
that one doesn't seem super reliable
let's see
here's another stream that we're going
to be monitoring
okay good so this is giving us this is
giving us some options
people saying status coup
is streaming let's see jordan chariton
status queue
not seeing it let's see slash live
not seeing a status quo uh stream right
now but we will we will monitor it
uh a guy under a tree with a laptop
all right so things things seem to be
relatively calm for the time being
but we will continue watching it
uh
very good yeah only about 13 minutes
left until this is supposed to be
getting started thanks to back a blast
for signing up via twitch appreciate
that appreciate that very much um also
over on the website people dumping in
memberships really quickly just as a
reminder we have this code please know
riot that's today's code we don't want a
riot here today and we hope that there
isn't one but
you can get a 70 discount off of a
membership on my website with the code
please know riot i want to say thanks to
amir mccord
as well as kevin black
james wormley and christopher zamora all
for signing up there let's take a listen
to what's
so the happening protester just came in
but i think you can see how many people
are media here
up there is falcon capital the u.s
police dc police
it's rare that falcon gets to fly over
the capitol
it's mostly reporters right now yeah
that's absolutely true
i don't know who's out there
but everybody's circling in this area
all right
so all of these streams
we can hear the chopper in all of them
which is interesting let's see if news
to share has gone live again
no it's really too bad news to share had
like the best stream
and it just disappeared it just it just
got pulled offline and we don't we don't
really know why
um
and then people told me status quo would
be streaming
but i am not seeing any live stream
so again if anybody has a specific
stream
they think that i should be
monitoring
please let me know there just seem to be
a little bit of commotion here let's
listen
[Music]
can't play
so he's been taken away
all right it looks like we've had the
first arrest
first of many
there was a uh anti-trump protester
screaming and starting fights with
others well not sorry others were
starting to turn into a fight
so the police took him out of the scene
wait that only the anti-trump protester
has been taken away so far
trump merchandise presented very
strongly here
um here we are near the stage
so we'll be monitoring that and again
just a few minutes from the start of
this
uh here we are in the crowd
and then uh i think this is will johnson
walking around here
so i'm being told news to share hit
their data limit
which is really too bad
um i'm also being told that there is a
facebook stream of some kind let's see
if we can close a few things here
so this one we don't need
i don't think newsmax is going to cover
it me having coffee is old news so i
think we can close that out
um people are sending me a facebook link
on twitch you can't paste links maybe if
you just describe the facebook channel
that's covering it i can find it because
the links are not going to be able to be
pasted there i do want to say a huge
thank you to baddie addie for gifting
five subs on twitch also thanks to yo
samurai and be money numbers 35 and 36.
also i want to remind you we do have a
one day oh this is the today's the only
day this code will work other than
forever because we never cancel the
codes but we at least have to say this
is one day only
please know riot is a code that works on
my website
inga bowen just signed up
alan slacker
and flake redmond all signing up on my
website really appreciate everybody
supporting the rare weekend stream
um
let's see
will johnson is live in dc yeah we have
the will johnson stream i think it's
this one right will johnson yep so let's
listen into that at that feed
this is the stage let's try to do
something here this is the stage up here
and keep the sunlight off of
it all right so there's will johnson
uh we'll just keep an eye on news to
share but it really just seems like
their stream is dead due to overuse of
data they went overboard from the
standpoint of data
status coup does not seem to be live on
the ground
will johnson is
i love the jogger just coming through
that's a nice touch
and here we are close to the front of
the line
uh the event scheduled to start right at
the top of the hour so we are monitoring
all of it let me look at a few other
super chats here david i hope we get a
geraldo rivera opening al capone's vault
vibes today yeah i hope i hope nothing
happens
i hate how similar new jersey's flag and
don't tread on me are i've noticed that
i'm a retired u.s coast guard veteran
now i live in the philippines watching
you great job my man thank you john
news to share is streaming
all right let's see
let's see if i go to slash live
yeah i'm not able to find their stream
let's see justice for j6
and then we look at live
penguin we got will johnson we've got
let's see this one the black
conservative preacher is apparently
streaming
okay so we got that one
uh
here's one other stream
yeah a lot of these are just in this you
know someone's gonna have to oh hold on
now police are involved
[Music]
could we get a mic on this guy
that's chief conte
that's the dc police chief chief conte
and i think he's i don't know if he's
negotiating is he interviewing the cops
or if he's actually they're trying to
talk out some stuff like you guys try to
keep away over here
i'm sorry
sorry
so
someone's really going to have to make
their way up to the stage at some point
soon because this is about to get
started let's listen to this interview
all of the messages and i'm pretty sure
that you've seen them where they're
telling people don't go don't go
have you seen anything out of the
ordinary have you seen anything like
would cause people not to show up
people don't believe in democracy at
this point it's really sad thing to see
when people are getting scared out of
exercising their most basic and
fundamental right to peacefully assemble
to protest and exercise their free
speech
the fact that you guys didn't show up
oh boy saying all these things like it's
a trap it's just
wow so this guy seems to have fully
bought in everything
the capital which you cannot open the
door
unless somebody from the inside opens it
and why doesn't pelosi run what a
release of 14 000 hours
of state
that would show that released the dapes
she wants a narrative because she thinks
it will get a more vote for her party
americans are waking up they're seeing
the truth
okay and whether you're a democrat
you're a republican we're here together
we're not against each other
they are political prisoners we support
them right
and god bless america all right a
message of peace and unity on this very
very special day um it looks like this
stream is making its way up to the stage
where things are supposed to get going
uh momentarily
we'll take one more look to see if we
have a stream from status quo if not i
might just get away from it yeah we can
close this out it doesn't look like
status quo
is uh streaming
so things are getting okay and now we're
very close to the stage so i think we'll
keep it here since we're just moments
away from this presumably from the start
of this i want to say thanks to people
that are signing up on my website i
really appreciate your support today um
using the code please know riot
sean mulvey has just signed up so is
courtney kemper i want to say thanks to
larry last name
haley martinez and robert morales all of
whom have signed up and putting us at 44
today
also over on twitch moog mt as well as
breezy
have signed up that puts us at 46. you
see these kind of like fake secret
service guys that are here at the front
there's a lot of
a lot of larping and kayfabing happening
and um
i think soon something is going to start
what exactly what what is the program we
don't really know
um
but there will be
i believe some kind of speech
let's look at some other super chats
coming in
sir man dude says all i hear is wow
exactly where is all the biden
merchandise yeah i mean if these are
democrats and republicans you'd think
there'd be some biden merchandise
penguin six is live streaming yeah
that's one of our feeds actually that's
this feed this is the penguin six feed
who were the expected speakers i have no
idea
i couldn't tell you i've no idea
whatsoever who's expected to speak here
um
some kind of patriots i guess
i don't know
we'll see we'll see pretty soon
hey thank you for that donation as you
guys know i don't use your donations i
don't need your donations but i do spend
your donations on the homeless so right
if we see somebody who's hungry today
we're going to buy them lunch thank you
very much but please i don't i really
don't need the money and
if you really want to help you could
probably just donate to your local
charities too yeah
uh the guy in the kilt is mustang medic
this guy should really be promoting the
please no riot coupon code i think it's
a missed opportunity to really uh bridge
live streaming elements and uh
i think that that would be a really
really appropriate thing to do
um
thanks to everybody who's watching on
twitch by the way we've really been
making a big push there and we're we're
hoping to get our first hundred thousand
followers there soon we're at i think
about 86 000.
um
i i no word yet whether mango pricing
will be a big topic today during the uh
during the event but we will monitor
that i would be curious if there are any
denounce denouncements
of mango pricing up under joe biden so
we're going to monitor that really
closely i want to say thank you to
tamara svaboda for signing up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
please know riot we've just lost penguin
six video briefly but it'll it came
right back
um
let's see who's closest to the stage
right now
we're here for the people that were
thrown in prison that should not be in
prison right we're not even here just
for the people who are peacefully
walking the
there are people outside the capitol
that stop the police officers from
murdering more people oh my god they
killed roseanne boylan in front of
everyone that's the reason why the
police officer was dragged down the
steps because they killed roseanne
boylan that's what we would call an
alternative story about what took place
on january 6th
um
[Music]
yeah
let's see if we've got any new streams
that have come online also i want to see
whether zach petrizo has added anything
to his coverage because he's on the
ground there
let's see what he's got going justice
for j6 organized matt braynard
approached the two guys with the far
right three percenter flags and told
them they weren't allowed to fly them
justice for j6 organizer matt brainard
is being protected by a security guy
with a single singular airpod yeah so i
guess this guy who we thought was low
rent secret service is actually the
organizer
and this guy's got one airpod just in
case there's anything he needs to hear
there
um
justice for j6 organizer matt brainard
asked by characters calling the event a
setup responds do you see a setup
while overlooking a field of few rally
goers
that's interesting
alright so great work there by our
friend zach petrizo
down on the ground
um
here we have a delegation of police
coming through
and looks like something is getting
going
it's all starting to feel like tension
is building in a way that's not great
police now kind of starting to move
people around
no he's gone
and he's gone so
let's make our way back over this way
they got another bike unit going i don't
know who's playing music
so it looks like another gentleman was
taken away
um that's
i mean thing i don't i don't know
uh we're
reportedly very cl i mean the start is
supposed to be now the first speech is
supposed to be now and i just don't know
i mean we're not
nobody's really near oh i think this guy
maybe is near the stage
i would love just a shot of the stage
quite frankly
but uh let's see if we've got
any new streams right up at the stage
it's not exactly the most well-covered
rally
so far
um
let's see if there's any new stream it
seems like the penguin six stream is a
pretty strong one
uh
black conservative preacher we've got
going
yeah we've got most of these streams up
and running
so hopefully one of them will will kind
of give us a sense of what's going on
there's another individual reporting
from the event
[Laughter]
very light turnout so far as you guys
can can obviously see i want to say
thanks to twisted hawk harry as well as
dimi bob for signing up and supporting
via twitch and twitch prime i appreciate
that also over on the website remember
that we have a today-only coupon code
this is very the code is please no riot
we don't want there to be a riot today
my ideal thing is this peter's out in
the next 15 minutes and we all go our
separate ways and have a good weekend
that's my hope we don't know if that
will happen but we do have this code
please know riot you can use it on my
website joinpakman.com very easy to use
i want to say thanks to laura tambernino
for using it
kathy fagia has just signed up
cricket martin is a new member so is
alicia fowzer
and sue stanger uh all signing up on my
website putting us at 55. very much
appreciate that
people asking if the national guard was
deployed i my understanding is that it
has been deployed
uh dark pepsi says older super chats to
read when you get the chance yeah we're
trying to work through everything
john says i live in cebu philippines
mango capital of the world mango prices
are stable no worries dude excellent
the fbi used to persecute actual
activists like fred hampton and said
they were terrorists it bothers me that
they are co-opting actual history
sir i've heard diamond and silk will be
performing tunes from hamilton on the
main stage somehow i doubt that
chakaseki says i heard the impending
evergrand default in china may affect
mango derivatives and mango mortgage
swaps in america please advise yeah i i
believe so
forget mango pricing what about tin foil
pricing yeah tin foil prices are off the
charts
it's actually crazy what's going on
reuters on twitter all right let's look
for that
uh
reuters twitter
let's see what reuters on twitter has i
might close this feed because that's not
doing too much for us
let's see oh very good
[Music]
reuters has a feed that's excellent
are these the same
they seem to be two different feeds oh
no that's just a clip this is life
[Music]
we'll just keep it right here
okay good
[Music]
all right good
some of these streams maybe we can close
i think i'm going to close this one
[Music]
don't tread on me flag a staple of these
events
[Music]
okay
so we're keeping an eye on everything
this was scheduled to officially start
about seven minutes ago it doesn't seem
to have started quite yet
there's a lot of memorabilia and
paraphernalia available there
um
[Music]
and it looks like this is pretty close
up to the stage
you said you're not in support of it
what's your views on it ben
what do you mean
no interviews man
ain't gonna be no attacking today
hopefully right
all black lives matter right
just making sure on all sides
all right man be safe okay
guy clearly did not want to be
interviewed that was clear
so i think at this point it's clear
there's more than 30 people but it is
really hard to tell how much of this is
media
and how much of it is faux security and
how many of these are actual
participants
um
i mean i would it be fair to say it's
probably in the hundreds right now
i don't know
it's my instinct
about what's going on here
um i want to say thanks to crazy
hawaiian in pennsylvania as well as tr
napsta for signing up and supporting via
twitch prime i very much appreciate that
also thanks to everybody who's been
using the coupon code please know riot
you can actually the best way to support
our stream particularly weekend streams
is to sign up on joinpakman.com using
this code please know riot
tremendous code on on uh
heretofore
unused code
um
other super chats are just coming in
very quickly organizers expect expected
today to be a tet offensive they wanted
trumpers to attack locals and state
capitals but it didn't work i i had not
heard that
um hopefully nothing bad happens today
not that i'm in defense of the maga
sheep but is a peaceful protest too much
to ask
um did i see hackers took down the texas
republican website and linked it to
planned parenthood no
david a lot of big talk for today but
i'm calling bluff
yeah obviously i hope that there's no uh
that there is no riot that's why the
code is please no riot i mean that's
that's the goal
i want to say thanks to david gazdecki
who just signed up at joinpackman.com
with the code please know riot very much
appreciate that
um
[Music]
yeah i don't know what's happened to the
schedule it was supposed to start at
noon but so far it doesn't seem like it
has let's look at the reuters feed they
are right up at the stage
[Music]
i've got the audio boosted as loud as
it'll go
by the way i think billy joel would be
disgusted by the use of his music at
this event there's just no way no way
[Music]
okay so
we're watching for the start of the
speech it should be any moment
and it's unclear what kind of statements
they're going to make
so this guy seems to be near this guy
right i think that's what's going on
this guy is standing to the side of this
guy who's streaming right right now as
well the super chats but if you want to
really support me yeah support me right
there support me right there what you
see united american affairs dot com four
slash donate go there and support me
there if you want to support me and
again like i said i do appreciate the
super chat i just got a feeling that
youtube is probably going to take this
video down oh
i don't know why why they would do that
washington monument it's about 15 blocks
from here
i put that up in my video yesterday if
you guys see that video yesterday
you can see that stuff
i have no idea who's going to speak
um
oh i'm being told that the reuters
youtube is something to look at
let's take a look at that
see what we can find
reuters
is this one it
i think it is
[Music]
now is this different it's the same as
this one i'd rather have it on youtube
though so actually that that makes sense
very good
all right we're monitoring thank you to
tommy garazzi
for signing up at joinpacman.com also
thanks to demont perry using that coupon
code please no riot numbers 59 and 60
today
and lastly thanks to have one and
who subscribed via twitch and says david
sir have you ever seen the cat in the
hat no i mean i've read it
i don't know about i don't know that i'd
use the word seen to describe it
[Music]
um police standing this guy in
particular standing very strongly
and police seemed far more prepared
today than they were on january 6th
and uh
any moment now things expected to get
going
we'll see if anybody uh oh this is up
closer
what's even happening here
your counterpart the black guy what's
his name
he was too racist we can't have racist
people oh my god did you guys get
arrested for january 6 yet no we're not
going to that's why we're out here
oh my god it's the crazy one corrine
we got one of those types back in the
central valley as well
i'm told dylan
uh is on the ground and live um is that
only twitch
let's see
if it's true i'll be i'll be on with
dylan uh on wednesday by the way
we've just got a short ad here
um
heavy heavy police presence
oh things are getting going i want to
make
measured for sure uh the handcuffs from
the fbi swoops in to take us all away we
all got a wrist measure right we came in
i've got the audio is high i've got it
boosted 600 percent with volume mastery
one
is that there are uniformed officers
here
who we you i demand that you respect
you're kind to you're respectful to and
you're obedient to
they're here to keep us safe we're
counting on them to do that and we know
that they will
there's also
many members
of the media here
and i i make the same request i make the
same request of them you see somebody
the member of the media be kind and
respectful they may ask you if you'd
like to be interviewed now if you're not
used to this i would recommend that you
don't because you've gotten a lot of
misrepresentation they're trying to say
that this is a rally in support of the
violent people who attacked and killed
police officers on january 6 and that is
absolutely not what this is about and
that has been misrepresented
continuously tell us what it is
so we condemn violence political
violence in all of its forms yes
we don't want any today and we condemn
the political violence that happened on
january 6. anybody who engaged in that
kind of violence or property destruction
that day
deserves to be
tried with a speedy trial
and found guilty locked up for a long
time there's no argument from anybody on
our side on this issue
this is about the many people who were
there that day who have not been charged
with violence not been accused of
assaulting a police officer destroying
property and this treatment they've
received
this is about equal treatment under the
law this is about the public
investigation to many of the things that
happen that have not been investigated
publicly or third-party oversight
especially the death of ashley babbitt
uh-oh
now that has been investigated
and this is about transparency because
we have a real issue with transparency
in the aftermath of january 6.
thousands and thousands of hours of
videotape denied not just from us
but from defense attorneys who need it
mysterious investigations into capital
police officers behavior
ambiguous press releases saying that
some were sanctioned for something but
we're not going to say what it is
this is unheard of in police departments
across the country or if it's not it
should be and it should be
same here with the capitol police so
we condemn all violence political
violence
i'm demanding that you all are
respectful and obedient to police
officers today in fact i'd like to start
off can we please have a round of
applause for the many police officers
who are here today
wow
what a guy
what a guy
now what this protest is not about
it's not about president trump
it's not about president biden it's not
about the election it's not about what
you think happened with the election
it's so weird it's like the protest is
not about anything he's listed 10 things
it's not about
message flag take it down they were very
respectful they did that i'm grateful
this is about
justice
and disparate treatment and equal
treatment under the law
and i understand i'm going to speak to
the many people in the audience who look
at us and say you're just insurrection
2.0
i understand
i understand you hate president trump
and everything about his administration
i get it i get it and i'm not here to
argue with you about that okay that
doesn't mean you have to hate what we're
standing for today
it doesn't mean you have to hate our
cause and what we're representing
that hatred is blinding you to a grave
injustice being perpetrated by our
government against many of our fellow
citizens this is like the richard wolf
destiny debate where they spent the
entire time listing what the debate was
not about here today doing the exact
same thing it's all on our supporters
[Applause]
so uh we're going to have a prayer to
start things off and what's a very
important part of this prayer naturally
is more where america first we meet we
start with the prayer pledge we have the
anthem
will the anthem be completely abortive
lives in the aftermath of january 6
for the many people who died on january
6th
and that's extremely unfortunate do you
regret that that shouldn't happen and
they are they're close to our hearts and
seeking our prayers so we're going to
open up with a prayer for my good friend
that dad won't you come up here
do we do the prayer do we silence it
good afternoon i'd like a moment of
silence for the uh americans and the
police officers
perished on j6 please bow your heads and
give them a couple minutes of silence
and ask for god to bless them couple
minutes
uh during this moment of silence uh that
they are holding a confusing moment of
silence i want to say thank you to abe
gilbert for signing up on my website
thanks to terry sanders robert peters
kathy gavel and laura benavento putting
us at 66. we do have this code please
know riot today we don't want a riot
here um also thanks to cavern thistle
for signing up via twitch
joinpakman.com is the place to do it
welcome everybody if you're just joining
us we're monitoring a bunch of different
streams
and
it is a very very strange event so far
mostly discussing what the event is not
about
i pray for the police that are here
that they also return to their families
tonight unharmed and safe
and i pray for these united states our
leaders our people dear god help us as a
nation and a people help us to overcome
all of the differences that strike
between us help us to live you and to
live to love and to serve you as your
servants and to come together as one
nation is this still the prayer
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all help us dear lord let's see what
dylan burns has got going check on that
but the next night when the proud boys
were still active the cops got in there
and they got active all right well we
don't we don't want to miss the main
event for now so we'll keep it here find
the grace and the strength may they find
the strength in the goodness
and feel your love to overcome their
hardships that they're now enduring and
may they have the rights that they are
guaranteed under our constitutions
and i pray especially for the men and
women of our own services may you watch
over them help them and guide them hold
them in their families or your hands and
protect them as they protect us bless
them and their families for the
self-sustains they do in our time i've
really got the audio boosted as much as
i can whatever god you believe in amen
wow amen
yeah and now we're going to have ned
lead us in the pledge thank you oh my
god okay the pledge of allegiance
that's your left hand dude
do you guys see him put his left hand
over that was weird
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty
is this like is this satire
now
this is a little bit of a different
turnout than we had several months ago
at the department of justice
who here was at that rally and i
recognized police take notice who here
was there rally we had at the prison a
little bit of a bigger crowd
we actually have one person who's also
here or a couple they were also with us
at the united nations a few weeks ago
can we hear from y'all
but you see the crowd now
and this is because of persistence
our message
is reaching our fellow american citizens
we already have poll numbers that show
essentially half of the public
believes
that the government is holding political
prisoners that came from rasmussen
and it's not rasmussen is bogus and most
people probably didn't even understand
the question
in fact yesterday i had a wonderful
interview which is uh you can see the
full live stream because i don't chop it
up put the live full live stream up with
my good new friend from msnbc missy
asman
and after the interview a guy who had
watched the whole thing
i've never recognized before came up and
started to be rather critical of the
line of questioning
saying that it was completely
misrepresenting what this rally was
about they can't hate every person
hitting a police officer with a fire
extinguisher or violence like that what
does miss yaz mean
the people who walked in a few hours
later not knowing what they're doing and
are now domestic terrorists they can't
be painted with the same crawl crush and
what was interesting to me is he said
look i'm a liberal democrat
this is about
is he referring to miss yasmine as she
or is was this a camera guy now this is
about civil rights
and i'm going to bring somebody up to
say the pledge who's been persistent and
consistent with us she's been at all of
our rallies uh miss monk will you please
get up here i'm sorry and sing the
national anthem she has
oh this now this is going to be
interesting let's see do we think she's
is she going to be really good in prison
we also said a prayer for the many
others incarcerated who have nothing to
do with j6 who've been abused in the
prison system and i'm sure it's endemic
everywhere and this is an issue that
should concern every moral human being
and it's something that concerns me and
i know many of the or all of our look
ahead america supporters here and she is
a champion for this cause here in d.c
she wasn't necessarily on her side
politically but she saw the treatment of
those people on january 6
in the prison right now particularly
those who have not been charged with
violence and she's been a long time
advocate for the many people held in
that prison really proud to have her
joining forces with us
mrs please sing a beautiful national
anthem like i know you can then followed
by kimberly guilfoyle i just want to
first say thank you to matt and i don't
just mean thank you for that interview
or the introduction i want to say thank
you for the work that you are doing on
behalf of american citizens who are over
in that detention center right now
and i want to also let you know for
everybody thinks that your voice doesn't
matter that you can't do anything well
me and a small group of people like matt
have been fighting since april wouldn't
it be i and a small group to get
awareness to not only these inmates for
january 6 but the torment that is going
on in our detention center due to the
covet protocols they are forced
vaccinating people they are coercing
people by keeping them in solitary
confinement this is the woman from the
wendy's hamburgers right
we fought we called congress we wrote
letters we went on interviews and i got
four we got four members of congress to
go knock on the door
[Music]
i'd rather her talk about whether
american cheese is really cheese you can
do it too never give up your ability and
your voice to make a difference
this country is for all of us
it's for all of us americans on the
right and on the left this is the
introduction to the national anthem who
believes that freedom still lives under
that flag i'm going to sing about right
now
[Applause]
hold on hold on before you do that
remember the green shirt
i am brian
i am master of the universe
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
okay i mean it could have been worse
real quick as we wait for them to get
the feedback where we can see it i i
can't tell you how thankful i am of all
the people signing up on my website we
have this code please know riot uh
people using it include timothy driggers
ramon palmquist
amanda love
kathleen coppola eratosthenes
roy branford
william buehner and maureen murphy
putting us at 74. i really appreciate
that as well as everybody signing up via
twitch uh i don't know why we are not up
at the front we're gonna look for a feed
that tells us exactly what's happening
at the front
although none of these fee oh here we go
what's happening
this will johnson feed continues to be
cut
ruptly has the best feed on youtube
youtube let's see
it's a personally thank matt for
organizing this day today which take a
look around do you see an insurrection
who watched the news this week who read
the media who who was terrified to come
here
you know shame on the people the system
that put fear in the hearts of american
citizens to stay home and to not come
out many who have called me and messaged
me begging and pleading for me to stay
home because they fear for my life and
my freedom what kind of america has this
become when people are afraid to come
out and protest
this is a peaceful protest and before i
present some information to you later on
i would like to introduce one of the
family members of the detainees in dc
jail who is right now as we speak being
held in solitary confinement her name is
kelly she's the girlfriend of jonathan
melis i would like to bring her to the
stage
kelly
and she's going to read a letter so
everybody please welcome kelly
[Applause]
to stand up for the first okay
um and human rights across the country
i'm here for jonathan melis but i'm
going to read another letter that was
written by somebody's mother who
actually shares a wall with john so
she's going to read not her letter but a
letter written by someone else well
john's in solitary confinement he has
been for no reason that's a whole story
but last night for dinner they were
served four pieces of white bread a
cookie and a packet of tartar sauce
according to them that's a nutritious
meal and they violated their own rule
book on multiple occasions so i think
america needs to become very well versed
in the treatment of these men it's human
rights that we're talking about and it's
completely nonpartisan
they suddenly seem to care about jail
conditions
dear not brainerd
i just got off the phone after speaking
to my son
he's a january 6th detainee in the gulag
of dc
over the months i have heard of the
horrors these u.s citizens as soon as
the pro-trump people are in jail
suddenly they're gulags have you guys
noticed that
indignities forced upon them
he told me he's not allowed to shave or
cut his hair it's been seven months now
with no shave or haircut as a veteran he
is supposed to be meeting with a veteran
representative weekly
he has yet to meet with one how can our
country treat it supposedly the pickles
used in the tartar sauce are half sours
they're not even dills i'm quickly
losing all confidence in our great
nation
initially he was granted bail redacted
only to have it overruled by a judge in
dc this judge made a statement that she
wants all federal judges to be hired on
the insurrectionists how is this allowed
the crowd is not super engaged as you
guys can see lost his job lost friends
family is in and is in the process of
losing his home he's denied visits from
family his jailers treat these men like
scum there's absolutely no presumption
of innocence it's funny because
i would generally agree with some of the
general critiques they're now making of
the prison system but they only now care
whereas all this other time it's like
let these people rot i would like to see
such treatment in the united states
i have watched some of your rallies and
wish i could afford to attend i know
that you sometimes read letters by
family members if you should happen to
read this hunter please don't reveal his
name i don't want any retaliation to
give him to him thank you for all of
your efforts and please keep up the good
fight sincerely
most people not even clapping
next up i'm going to introduce jeff zink
he's the father of one of the
politically persecuted
one of the political detainees and i
can't imagine what it would feel like to
be a parent and have a child in prison
right now being held in solitary
confinement with no bail thinking that
you brought this kid up in america where
there's a constitution and there's due
process and now your son or your
daughter i want to say thanks to cody
schumacher for signing up on my website
thanks to eric booth as well as richard
mcfarland all using the code please know
riot as we continue on here in dc
[Applause]
good afternoon everybody
first and foremost i want to tell you
that i was here on january 6th
i could damn
the violence
i condemn the things that took place
that were not american not patriotic
this america is about peaceful protest
and that's what i expect all of us to do
as well
so why are we here
i don't know it seems that this
place is decided and the government has
decided to start suppressing
american citizens their first amendment
rights
they can't speak out
it's times like what's it what's he
talking about that good men and women
need to stand up that are called by god
what happened on january 6th i can give
you a first-hand account
we the people came to hear
a message
what we came to do is to go and
peacefully
let our voices be heard
as matt said earlier this is not about
trump this is not about
democrat or republican i still don't
understand what this is about it's not
about supporting the rioters it's not
about trump it's not partisan it's not
violent it's not like what it what is
this about silent
we must bring light to what is happening
to the prison chase police officers down
the hall what the heck
this is the ruptly feat everybody wanted
and it's been good but now they've cut
to something else let's see what this is
[Music]
if you
that's who they are this is a counter
protester it sounds like it's about
today
it's about changing the narrative
because they have a loser argument
and the loser argument
hundreds of hours
of video and photographs and recordings
that they took
they were proud of what they did
don't forget their patreons
they're left to come down here and try
to get us what's that huh
their
felons
their traitors their domestic terrorists
are
let's see what else we have going on
this is reuters now
[Music]
i actually think they should stop
filming this lady
cool thanks hey where are you from
man this is really a mess
[Music]
have the police created are the police
kind of encircling someone they want
people staying away from i don't even
get what's what's happening this is all
wacky
this stream keeps cutting so we're gonna
we're gonna actually cut it here's the
black conservative preacher still
streaming from close to the front
it's all kind of falling apart
uh here's dylan burns looks like he's
now been able to get sort of close to
the action
this government wants to keep us silent
they want us out of the way
i will not be one of those that are
going to be
silent
i am not going to be afraid
i will not bow down
my name is jeff zeke
and it's time for people like you to
stand up and start talking for these
people
thank you
thank you so much jeff so we had another
guest she was unable to make it a crazy
story her no her name is nicole riffett
she
was flying here she was detained at the
airport
brought to her hotel room her computer
was trashed by the fbi
and she was unable to attend what
i just found out it's crazy she was
supposed to be guest speaker her
computer was trashed by the fbi
the fbi came to my house twice for
peacefully protesting
at the capitol i was nowhere near the
building and i've been terrorized twice
by the fbi and that's left an indelible
mark on my mind and it makes me want to
fight harder for the other people that
are being persecuted it seems that it's
caused her to now have delusions of
grander actually
i'm sorry to read nicole's letter
so that she had to write and send us
a text message a lot of letters huh
because it's now in possession of the
fbi hershey said my husband political
prisoner three seven six seven eight two
guy is named
he was arrested for rhetoric and charged
with a thought crime he has been held in
solitary for over 40 hours he's been
charged with a thought crime what
without representation
uh oh
is dylan let's hope dylan's not over his
bandwidth
extremists
we are all if you listen to the media
but for what a political ideology
and even with all that i consider us
blessed guy gets to have his day in
court ashley babbitt and roseanne boylan
who we'll talk about later did not get
that chance
say their names ashley babbitt roseanne
[Music]
let me say a few other names of actual
american heroes people signing up on my
website thanks to christian bear as well
as janet dahler
leah howard and jamie mcnee everybody
who i just named and we say their names
today just grabbed a membership on my
website using the coupon code please
know riot i encourage you to do the same
i also want to say thanks to jay
tandoway for gifting five subs and too
damn lucky this puts us at 86 and that's
a much stronger number than i've heard
presented so far by any of these
but speakers with a potential jury pool
and perpetrating fear when in reality
the only thing to fear is being
complacent
see if you're not charged with
the mainstream media
is this dylan's real-time commentary on
top of it our own nation's capital to
exercise our first amendment right
that was promised by our forefathers and
criminalized by the current
administration
but we the people will not be afraid
whether it is
1776 or 1 621
we are people we the people are the
guardians of our own sovereignty not the
government
[Music]
and that they're lying about our
patriots rotting in dc jail without due
process
we are being used
i'm told that the news 2
stream feed is back or something like
that uh justice for j6 let's see if we
can find that because that was a good
stream before they got cut off
uh we'll filter by live
um where is it
not actually seeing it
i mean we have quite a few feeds
all right oh news to share they are back
let's see
we'll see what's going on
in the meantime
guy came to dc for a redress of his
grievances like hundreds of thousands of
others that day which is the right of
all americans but the simple truth is
is that is that it's only your right if
your ideology falls in line with that of
the status quo
that is not what our forefathers and
others have given
up their all for
okay
we the people will not be intimidated we
will not retreat we the people will not
leave our patriots to waste the way in
jail without a voice without liberty
giving up for the letter from nicole
props
who unfortunately next they'll be
reading some letters from ernest
hemingway written during his time in
cuba computer was taken by the fbi and
she's now on a note
for coming to d.c to peacefully protest
as a speak on behalf of her loved one
who was in dc prison
[Applause]
[Music]
so i'm going to dedicate this speech i'm
going to make trying to make my speech
fast i had a lot of stuff to say but you
know what hold on a second she hasn't
started her speech yet pizza us or
www.thepeoplesjanuary6commission.com
if you want to find out some truth that
i've been investigating i now consider
myself an investigative journalist and
i'm asking you and the mainstream media
to listen to what i'm saying because
stuff that the government has told you
that you have been reporting and i'm
going to give you the benefit of the
doubt that you didn't know has been
inaccurate as we all know there was one
death that day a homicide that day and
that was ashley babbitt but there was
another woman that day that the media
said dried up died of a methamphetamine
metha amphetamine um
this is an interesting superchat this is
white privilege on steroids
um the redhead singing the national
anthem was interviewed by jordan klepper
that's interesting i have uncovered
video and like i said go to my website
did she say a corvid video or a carpet
video show you the video i'll give you
the link to the video of roseanne boylan
being beaten severely as she lay
unconscious on capitol steps by a
metro dc police officer who i have
identified and i know her name and if
you want to go on my website you can
find that out okay so roseanne boylans
next up the bald guy is going to tase
himself just to show how patriotic he
back the is i support the police but
when a police officer does wrong that
police officer needs to be held
accountable and amen and all the other
police that are here today need to agree
with me on that that an investigation
needs to
it's interesting because the opening was
this is not about defending the rioters
but like every letter and every speech
is just defending the rioters
[Applause]
[Music]
and we have reasons to believe to ask
for an investigation that perhaps they
were not again go on my website and see
video on that
i have one last message
and i'm going to direct this to nancy
pelosi
nancy pelosi who made a statement to the
mainstream media that people should not
come to this rally today and support
killers
to nancy pelosi i hope you're watching
or that someone sends you this video i
want to address you directly we're both
women we're both u.s citizens and we
both have the same how does she know
that it's protected under the same
constitution how dare you tell me or
other americans that love their country
not to attend a peaceful protest to
advocate against the abuses being
perpetrated on u.s citizens for the
events of january 6th
[Applause]
i don't even know what this lady's
talking about
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let's see if we can get back
to
actually hearing her her talk we're both
women we're both u.s citizens
this one's on a delay
protected under the same constitution
how dare you
tell me or other americans that led
their country not to attend a peaceful
protest to advocate against the abuses
he perpetrated on u.s citizens for the
events of january 6.
i take personal offense and so does
everybody
[Applause]
i'm here you are directly responsible
for stripping away the constitutional
rights of millions of american citizens
that do care and want to stand up and
attend this rally but you fear margaret
them into not
coming how could you be so heartless to
desecrate our first amendment
constitutionally protected right to
peacefully assemble people asking who
this is i have no idea she's been going
for a while reading various letters and
correspondence from different
your platform people contaminate their
jury pool by calling january 6 detainees
killers
uh oh
all right so that feeds in trouble
[Music]
[Applause]
causes so you can find out the name of
the police officer who beat roseanne
boylan as she lay on the capitol steps
unconscious we have the video and
there's other video under court order
that cannot be released to the public
that people have seen where it clearly
shows that a capital i mean sorry a dc
metro police officer beating her
senseless
and there's patriots being charged in
prison right now for trying to help the
her and trying to get the police
officers off of her that is why they're
being held right now in dc prison
it's the website and god help the waiter
that brings her overcooked veal parmesan
us or www the people's january 6th
commission
my name is kara keshnov if you want to
see the video please talk to me after
the rally i have no problem showing to
you thank you matt brainer this is a
peaceful amazing event just like he said
it would be on the news a lot of times
you guys you're free to
by saying this is not the second
insurrection they are conceding that the
january sixth one was an
and i thank insurrection every day
that we found each other that she has
the courage to stand up and do what she
did she did it all on her own she just
woke up one day
and saw an injustice and acted
and anyone if you can do the same
this is definitely gonna make a little
reminder um we've got a wonderful
security force the capitol police and
the other police forces who come far and
wide to make sure this is a safe event
are doing a fantastic job let's have
another round of play
keep clapping for the cops yeah i know
it's hot out here i know the last thing
they want to be doing today but
they're doing their duty we're proud of
them and we're grateful but i want you
to also know that you have a role in
security here too if you see any funny
business anything suspicious
all of you have a television studio
right in your pocket
take it out record it
and if somebody's causing trouble
they're going to have a bad time we're
going to make them famous okay so i
appreciate your cooperation in that
is this guy a feta male like feta cheese
i want to say thank you to kathy marsh
for signing up on my website h thomas is
a new member luis chavez has signed up
and efrain perez as well
i can't thank everybody enough uh for
supporting today's stream we do have
this coupon code we want no riot so the
code is please no riot you can use it on
my website joinpakman.com the discount
is ungodly i'm not even going to say how
big it is because this guy will come
after me um
but but i do appreciate everybody who's
been using it political leadership
has advised them
not to participate in our rallies today
now i read the constitution i think
maybe you read the same constitution i
did
my understanding is i don't know a lot
of these people are confused about
what's in it i'm wondering if they've
read a different one congressional
districts
they're supposed to work for us and
represent us they're where their bosses
right
who is their boss
and i think that some of them have
forgotten that
some of them seem to be more afraid of
the political leadership up there than
they are of their constituencies i mean
that an entirely peaceful way
but you guys when you go back to your
states i've got the volume as high as it
goes guys rallies we have coming up in
the next couple of weeks
they've cut away again so now we'll try
to find another feed hey can we come
speak to the crowd
so first i'd like to introduce a brave
patriot he's an entrepreneur a
businessman he started a trucking
company
okay
see if we can refresh this one this was
actually a good feed while it was going
to us or www they're like 20 minutes
behind so that's not going to work this
one's over let's see the dylan burns
feed they have passed
okay
this is quite a contrast
okay let's get away from that i mean
that just seems
not good i don't even know they reached
out to me and said hey can we come and
speak to the crowd
so first i like to introduce a brave
patriot he's an entrepreneur a
businessman he started a trucking
company down in georgia
he's very brave to be here today because
i know that his text messages and emails
and voicemails all full of people
telling him not to come it's a false
flag because somebody who only exists on
the internet told him it was
but they didn't listen he said they
recognized the problem they decided they
have to ask so first of all i'm curious
who this guy is collins
[Applause]
he has some letters to read
i strongly condemn political violence in
any form oh god especially the violence
that was perpetrated on january the 6th
or anybody who may commit violence here
today
those who committed violent acts
what a mess yeah this that that's the
problem with that feat it keeps going
out
um
and a lot of these feeds are just kind
of
not at the main stage let's let's listen
here
okay not a lot happening there
this is all pretty weird
when people say fox has the feet is that
the fox news youtube channel i would
look for that
chat is it good is it good chat
can you hear me chat
you can hear me now chad right
not seeing a like
yeah dill burns hey hold on hold on you
love myself stream here hey can i ask
you a few questions yes sure sure so
why'd you come here um just to see
what's up i mean
i haven't ever been to one before and i
just wanted to see what's up and take
pictures i'll have all the dogs i got
all the dogs so you like the dogs here
for the dogs the dogs are the protests
you know yeah so two types of [ __ ] oh
okay this this one's gotta feed here we
go it's just not true
what we do have we have political
prisoners here
in the media
well they're the biggest ally for the
left
they want you to believe that well this
is just another conspiracy theory
[Music]
but the facts i'm gonna tell you what
the facts are clear
we've got non-violent
misdemeanor offenders that are currently
be held they're being held with no bond
no access to lawyers
it's funny how suddenly they're
concerned about overuse of pre-trial
detention see trial until next year
i tell you what you won't find an
example of that from minneapolis
from when this nation's capital was on
fire in the summer of 2020.
i'll tell you what the american people
are not stupid
we can see it with our own eyes the
difference in the treatment from our
federal government because of someone's
political beliefs
and that's regardless regardless of how
the news media tries to spin it or what
they tell you
[Music]
those accused the j6 political prisoners
being detained immediately
especially those being held for
non-violent crimes
[Applause]
wow that was abruptly ended
keep clapping for people um this is
people asking for the reuters feed this
is the reuters feed it's not great
um the feeds
are going in and out from being good to
being not so good so
we'll do what we can do
[Music]
right now
okay so that's terrible let's now switch
here sorry i couldn't help but have a
deep felt respect this is a man who
served our country for 20 years overseas
on eleven combat deployments uh-oh in
the special forces
and he made the ultimate sacrifice i
think
that guy's being arrested it looks like
he's at least getting a talking
providing id sir am i being detained
looks like we may have an arrest
happening
[Music]
anybody know what he's holding above his
head
okay had in common with those i went to
war with was that we were all americans
our political leaders they didn't think
twice about sending us off on useless
endless wars that were of no gain but
all of us joined all of us fought many
of us died many of us still carry the
stars from war for one reason we believe
in this country we believe in that flag
[Music]
[Applause]
our fellow citizens when their
constitutional rights are taken if we do
not speak out against that we are guilty
of standing by and watching those rights
erode make no mistake what governments
it's like really still not clear what
the point of this is are they saying
that
the people that are being held for
rioting on the sixth are being held
unfairly
that the the prison system's a problem
the legal like the these aren't things
they cared about before but they're
defending the sort of strange people to
defend i'd be i'd be going after you
know if this was your issue i'd be
talking about like the non-violent drug
offenders for example it did not happen
here in america but that is running off
the rails right now because too many
americans just think that it's not their
business i'm not part of that political
party
those guys
that's not the way this works yeah this
rally is a violation of hipaa and a
violation of critical race theory
call your elected officials call your
representatives show up at every single
rally
look ahead america is having for these
political prisoners be their voice
because it's not even just about them
it's about our forefathers who gave us
these rights who fought who fought the
revolution it's about every single
veteran who's ever deployed overseas
who's ever been killed it's for everyone
in arlington national cemetery
the law
[Music]
i'll check matt brainard's stream in a
second it seems as though so far we're
missing any references to
hydroxychloroquine
ivermectin
um let's see matt brainard
let's see he seems to be here
um
we'll check out his stream
all of them that are here today i'm
extremely grateful for all of them that
were present on january 6 they are not
our enemies our our enemies are those
that will deny people of their
constitutional rights and then take a
narrative that labels all of us as
terrorists or insurrectionists for just
questioning uh-oh i'm being told dc
police are clamping down and arresting
everybody who used the code please know
riot everybody who's been using the code
apparently is getting getting pulled
into a paddy wagon ron dalarity has been
arrested
diana lee has been pulled in thomas
lavanway
don mass kelly danzig
mary d'angelos sharon mayer michelle
rostucci laura castro karen randall
and gio williams people are getting
pulled in for using the code which i
encourage you to use by the way at
joinedpakman.com in all seriousness uh
please no riot it's a great code lawyer
up lawyer up
hey robert are you ready to start
rolling pictures and stuff uh-oh okay
so um i want to show you guys people are
being unfairly held without bail for
using my coupon code
let's see a on the screen
now i don't know if you guys can see
that quite from the sunlight it looks
like the picture's a little cropped but
that's alexandria ocasio-cortez uh-oh
leading no no don't boo her no no we're
not booing we're not booming people
today okay we're not booing people
but that is her
insurrection right today they're not
booing people interfering with
government business trespassing parading
let's see the next picture
b let's go to b robert
the screen's lower than like people who
are six feet tall it's weird screen
placement
this man has not been accused of
destruction of property
he has been accused of dressing horribly
i think
it's a matter of opinion but what he did
that day
and if anybody did anything similar does
not deserve
nine months in solitary confinement
without conviction no conviction nine
months in prison
tonight bail
denied medical care he is
[Music]
in
suffering
his mother was going to come speak to us
today
but she was intimidated out of her first
amendment rights out of fear out of all
the fear-mongering surrounding this
so
all of you are out here for her because
she could not be out here
let's go to the next let's go to c
because this is kind of the point whoa
let's go i guess we're building to the
point of the rally soon
i'm sorry let's go to b2 robert let's go
to b2
[Music]
now i'll put that up there because i
showed you one picture i showed you the
second picture the truth is the same
picture
as people exercising the first amendment
rights in the wrong way and i admit it's
stupid and i admit there should be a
penalty to it i support it the thing is
is that historically at the kavanaugh
hearings
where people were arrested over and over
again for storming the senate off
calvina storm the hearings they arrested
bailed out went back and did the same
thing
that day
over and over again
it's the same picture
now robert the officer
it's the office i know because it's a
meme
what the hell okay forgive me if that
one went over anybody's head
a and b aoc and our shaman friend it's
the same picture they're doing the same
thing engaging the same behavior a very
different outcome why
not because of what they did but because
of what they believe that is
unconstitutional that is immoral
and that's what makes them political
prisoners so let's go to image
let's go to image c please
now whenever the media whenever i've
been interviewed lately the media always
likes to run this footage next to me of
the most violent moments of the rallies
of the protest on january 6. even though
i expressly say anybody engaged in
violence belongs in prison
he's about to put up my coupon code and
call it illegal balance activity assault
or destruction property they always run
the b-roll next to me because that's how
disingenuous they are that's just how
they operate right
can't do anything about it really
but that's pretty much those are the
people we're talking about these are
folks who are assembled and statuary
tall being peaceful now robert let's see
let's see image d please
right now
so those are people
illegally assembled
in that building being rounded up by
police officers with zip ties
they were all released that day and find
between thirty five and fifty dollars
[Music]
now i'm sure the message i'm trying to
send here is that this disparate
treatment that i seem to have to explain
to every reporter like six or seven
times
they don't seem to get it so maybe some
pictures will help them because i know
that everybody showed up here on behalf
of laa you all understand this this is
real
yeah if people want mercy bands the
moderators can start handing them out if
people need it
again
this image is from a hearing room
interfering with government business
this is the same thing that the
political prisoners have been charged
with if they've had the fbi break into
their house
it's not the individual agent's fault
really
it's their orders and the political
leadership back behind me and at the
department of justice
but
those people are having their doors
kicked in
and being rounded up in the middle of
the night and dragged washington dc
denied bail had their lives destroyed
losing their homes losing their jobs
some cases losing their marriage just
because of the stress of it all
these people did exactly the same thing
released that day
no one called it insurrection manny
barely reported on it and when they did
report on it was favorable
so he's droning on let's see what dylan
burns is up to trump's residency
um they were very they were a few very
small slightly targeted ones and they
were very specific and targeted unlike
the one biden did where they killed a
bunch of aid workers and children wasn't
like trump's first foreign like attack
like killed like an american girl
uh oh man dylan's having trouble keeping
the stream up smoothly how not that i
recall i was in
yemen
americans with the with the taliban in
afghanistan too i'm sure
just like there was that british girl
who went off to be a taliban bride it's
like gee you know i mean you mean the
nicest bride yeah well whatever
but yeah i mean people there are people
that are going to make those choices so
if it's totally possible that americans
are working with foreign enemies
i'd love to hear this but we keep it it
seems like there's a problem
let's see if we can set the quality
really low and see if it'll stay up
chinese plant here
2009 where we had like 2 million people
see a humanity from one end to the other
this place
i was here the you know several times a
year later i was down here surrounding
the capitol when they rammed obamacare
through
i've been down here they rammed it
through over like a year and a half
dozens of things over the last 12 years
and i think my
my activities of the last 12 years
speaking of themselves sounds like a
great way for china to start attacking
the integrity of the american people
well again i i've never advocated for
anything but the support and defense of
the constitution
and unfortunately our constitution has
been thrown away as long as these guys
are held without bail and without charge
america doesn't exist
two months ago the constitution has
fought is not is is not being upheld
supported or defended by our government
and released that day
so where are we if america doesn't exist
um we're about two years from china
taking over once the dollar collapses
two years from china taking over so so
you think that biden's going to deliver
us to china well look what he's done to
our military so far he's demoralized
them and and now by forcing the mark of
the beast on him it's like how many of
them are going to quit
yeah this guy's delusional there's
genetic mutation stabs that don't
prevent it oh my god well they didn't
none of those things meet the definition
of a vaccine vaccine has a definition
these are mrna therapies this guy knows
so much he knows about geopolitics he
knows about religion he knows about
vaccines
when you need to join the military you
need to get like a million vaccines like
most military members well those are for
known diseases itself that they did and
again a little bit of known disease
well this again it's that they haven't
done any proper research on any of it
this is a disease that came out of a
chinese bio weapons facility it's been
proven to be
99.97 percent survivable just like the
flu is that's a lie that still means
almost 700 000 americans though
no i would say 80 of those people we all
get vaccinated for the flu
yeah if you're like 70 to 90 i would say
you're
at risk
but it's like but right now seven times
more teenage males have been
hospitalized with cardiac complications
from
these genetic mutation shots that have
been hospitalized that's a lie too
so how safe is that i remember i don't
know man you're convincing me
okay we're gonna get away from that um
let's look now at the video they're
playing at the main
screen older
i remember there was a allegation of
religious texts being flushed down the
toilet in guantanamo bay
now that was a story for weeks and it
was covered despite the fact the media
knew that would result in violent
reaction
in iraq and elsewhere against our troops
and get our troops killed they knew that
but they still put it out there they
still put it out there god bless them
now i just wish they would have the same
fortitude when it comes to demanding the
release of these 14 000 hours of
videotape it seems like the kind of
thing the media would be curious about
it seems like they should be our allies
i mean most voya requests are filed by
journalists this entire um
release the tapes thing is now something
they repeat without even really knowing
like what they're talking about and if
the quote tapes were quote released they
wouldn't even know what to do with them
or what to look for in the tapes like
it's just you know they don't even know
what they're talking about
i don't want to get everybody out here
safely and we'll talk about that in a
minute
but i want to applaud you for a moment
because
it took real
courage to come out here today
all right let's see if we can get a
slightly wider shot of what's happening
now i just wish they would have the same
fortitude when it comes to this one's
very delayed
[Music]
[Applause]
you have my respect and i also am
entirely grateful to each of you for
trusting me
because i was the one that told you come
out here i was going to told you to get
here safely it wasn't a false flag and
so many voices on the left called your
killers and slandered you
and so many
i called them armchair patriots on the
right said this is a false flag attack
and you shouldn't come
and
my inbox is full i every i constantly
hear from people you should call it off
don't do it
but you stood up you withstood that and
i look
what is this is about a very important
cause but it's also broadly about
something much more important because
what the political leadership in this
country it's a dirty secret okay
when you're upset about a political
problem that you're angry
they actually want you to do what
happened on january 6th they want
violence from us
who's he talking about i've been saying
i mean look my code is please no riot
we've been saying i hope there is no
violence for two months now the law
they can deal with you very easily as
you've seen they send the afbi after you
go into the gulag especially if you're
guilty you deserve it
but what's the lesson that we've learned
from people like gandhi
or martin luther king or the civil
rights movement in this country
i'll tell you it terrifies them this is
what terrifies them
[Applause]
[Music]
is this the guy from that video game hit
man
very difficult job
when we show up at school board meetings
and use our first amendment rights we
educate our state legislators when we
come to washington and demand justice
peacefully
orderly
[Music]
it's not clear they're doing anything
it's funny to be like they won't stop us
what are you doing you haven't even
explained what you're doing
[Applause]
and i know
i know that many here many watching are
upset about the election i understand
and i'm upset too
but the reaction that we saw on january
6 it was stupid it was wrong and what
i'm asking you you know anger is
dangerous
anger gets turned inward it's
self-destructive
and it spills out and becomes
destructive to the world what i'm asking
you to do is take
do not give up on our constitution do
not give up on our country do not give
up on voting do not give up on
petitioning our governments
[Music]
[Applause]
give it to look ahead america help us
make this a better country help us save
this country
help us fix our election system
help us get justice
help us help us get our schools to
respect our history
and our founders
[Music]
is he actually winding down put you to
work it will be difficult
difficult to stand outside a costco for
30 minutes or for three hours in the hot
sun to register new voters that's
difficult especially when they
constantly kick us out
if anybody knows the ceo of costco i'd
like to chat with them because
we're doing god's work they should be
nice to us
those are our people
it's hard to register votes it's hard to
write letters it's hard to come out on a
date it's easy to sit behind a computer
and type it
right and spread this information in
fear that's easy coming out here is hard
and you will forever have my respect for
coming out here today you will forever
be have my gratitude
[Music]
[Applause]
so
look
may god bless you and before we go again
i can't emphasize this enough because
these guys are trying to persua
trying to portray us as standing up for
killers and people assaulted police
officers we hate that well that's what
you're doing anybody who's who's ever
done anything like that
does not belong in this movement is
condemned by look ahead america we
condemn it we condemn it we condemn it
but this is about desperate treatment
of the non-violent people this is about
the lack of transparency this is about
the great cause that kara said indicated
that there would have been additional
victims that day and we need
transparency we need that video
release the video let's get a cheer
going maybe the journalists will join in
with this because this is first
amendment stuff right come on
journalists
get ready for cringe
[Music]
what do we demand we don't know
when do we want it
now guys they're out here today you know
they're doing their best to do our job
they're ordered here by political
leadership who
uh i i appreciate everyone keeping this
safe today um a little bit of overkill
but look i respect it hey i'm in the
business
of community organizing okay the guy
says the presence of the police isn't
necessary but he brought in like 10
people to protect him but setting up and
keeping us all safe now that's not
that's not my area of expertise i really
respect the people came out the capitol
police have done a wonderful job
communicating with us letting us know
yeah i want to thank i i actually would
like to thank the individual officers by
name but that will only get them in
trouble so they know who they are the
ones who've been talking to him we've
been working with
um you have our eternal gratitude
respect so let's have a run for all the
police
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
instructions okay
so dc is a historically pretty dangerous
city
what i'm asking you to do is as you i
want you to leave we're going to play
exit music and my good friend my good
new friend robert knows we're going to
play on exit
[ __ ] on your way out
give a smile and a wave to any cop you
see okay just give them a smile wave
tell them we appreciate their service
any journalists
just smile but keep on walking
but stay in groups at least until you
get out of the district of columbia
because believe it or not unlike other
rallies i take your safety
personally it's my personal
responsibility and i'm going to be the
last one
along with my security team so the
sooner you get out of here the sooner i
can get out of here and we're going to
do this again someday we're going to
keep fighting hopefully not soon
end today in fact
i think this is the beginning
this is the beginning of the america
first right taking over community
organizing in this country
[Applause]
i'm so proud of you i could cry
i'm so proud of you all there's like no
one there
they've accomplished nothing and they've
not even outlined what they want
usa usa usa usa usa usa so
god bless you all leave in large groups
if you see somebody walking out alone
say hey why don't you come with us at
least since you're out of the district
of columbia
and i want you to stay safe and look
again you had to ignore a lot of people
to tell that told you not to come today
you heard it from everywhere but i want
you to go back out there and tell them
that we're not giving up on this
we're not giving up on protest culture
we're not giving up on petitioning our
government about the first amendment and
we're not going to be tempted by the
dark voices saying that apathy and even
violence are the only answers we reject
that and you go back home and you told
them you come to you came today
delusions and conspiracy theories seem
to be another answer anybody that told
you that this was a false flag attack or
a trap or anything like that remember
their names and never
god bless you all
america first
america forever
[Applause]
[Music]
that escalated quickly
so now is the point at which it if it's
going to get violent it will and we're
going to monitor it i do want to
continue thanking people signing up on
my website thanks to david hill diana
lee
and son to nikkinen all of whom just
signed up on my website using the coupon
code please know riot we're hoping for
no riot also over on twitch tough guy
ted
as well as thailand
fino
a web tx
lord neckbeard
the gaming dad
have all signed up very much appreciate
that
uh this event is now uh who knows what
the direction is going to be of this
event you can sign up at joinpakman.com
of course and that coupon code it will
be done today
uh please know riot let's listen
oh this is lauren windsor i think dumb
question she just asked why is the
security p why are the security people
mostly black
[Music]
this i have to hear in the audio just
cut these questions this is great
but the audio seems to have been cut
let's see if anyone else is covering the
questions
no oh why did the audio go away
that is really sad this oh
this is his youtube channel and the
questions are so triggering his own
youtube channel has cut the audio
i wish one of these other channels was
was covering this
this is too far to hear
this isn't anywhere close
here's dylan burns man that's really too
bad i would have loved to have heard
those uh questions
because they seemed so so uh he seemed
extremely triggered by them
um
wow
that's really too bad
i'm almost positive that that was lauren
windsor from the undercurrent asking why
why are the security people mostly black
today um
is lauren windsor streaming live let's
see
uh lauren windsor live let's see here
um
the undercurrent
let's see
yeah she's she's not she's not live
that's too bad
yeah they've cut the feed yeah didn't he
he does coke not crack yes yes i mean
and i'll also be planning the downfall
of america right um oh i don't know
about that did they find that on the
secret laptop i think they found out a
secret laptop oh that's cool hey you
from chat
uh what's chat
you're from chat like the stream chat
like my i have a chat i have a group
chat with my mom in it
okay man
um do you know me from somewhere
no who you are you famous
wait so how do you know i got wrecked in
that debate earlier i you got just
totally destroyed in that debate that's
all i know though
maybe like in my walls watching me at
night like how do you know how do you
this is weird
oh he was hovering around oh i thought
you were going to attack him too oh my
god i thought you were from chat i was
so yeah i was confused that's how you
about to stab me oh my god
my god what'd you think of that guy oh i
thought he was totally based he's very
based very based and very red built i
don't know what the flags mean but yeah
ooh i i can't think of anything cringier
than that conversation right there jason
we pay income tax some of us up to 40
yeah
that's not right that's criminal as it
is that's unconstitutional and if uh the
lawmakers don't get it together we're
going to do it again
nice talking to you thank you so much
have a good afternoon thank you
all right well that was some
some opinions
i don't know what this one says how far
off is trump for reveal
they misspelled reichstag
a lot of misspelled signs huh
wow
looks like things are just winding down
actually looks like there's
oh god don't tell me it got cut again
that's really too bad
i really wish this feed had the audio
but the matt brainerd people have cut it
that's too bad oh wait ntd
let's see if we can get ntd live they're
about to interview him
ntd live
doesn't seem like they're actually live
though
nope that's too bad
very very strange
this is the counter protest i guess
let's listen i don't know if people can
hear you though
yeah i don't know if you can hear them
um
yeah
so you were so this is the side of the
capitol
where everything was set up for the
inauguration correct or is that the
other side yeah that was an inauguration
no no but before the inauguration they
had scout
okay
but there's no accountability they're
not black flavors oh now dylan burns
seems to be talking to black
conservative preacher
was worldwide it was everywhere because
you're black doesn't mean anything
that's another good point slavery was a
worldwide mediocrity okay it was normal
back then obviously it's not okay but to
bring that up 200 years later and say
this is a reason for people to fight
against each other it makes no sense
it's over we're all no i'm not saying
i'm sick i'm agreeing with you are you a
descendant of ethiopia and which part of
ethiopia mackelly ethiopia so in mckelly
the two grains they're in a great big
civil war what's your position on that
i don't know i mean i'm going on in
chigra i mean you've been adopted your
family were what missionaries i okay
here's the thing
i'm an african immigrant by assimilated
my allegiance is to america
looks like the audio's back here
he's telling everybody to go home
[Music]
security guy checking his watch
[Music]
[Music]
this has really strange energy to me i
don't know it's everything about it's
weird all right matt brainerd now on the
move
[Music]
um
[Music]
it's funny
a good job doing what like it's not even
clear what the whole point of this was
great job
i want to say thanks to darren gross who
just signed up on my website with the
coupon code please know riot please know
right appreciate that very much
um
thanks to everybody in fact who's been
supporting today's stream
that's medea benjamin she's been on my
show before
my partner who's here
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that's medea benjamin um she's
she's
from code pink
[Music]
this is crazy why does she i don't know
why she wants a picture with him it's
all weird
[Music]
in the presence
[Music]
all of this is completely incoherent
like i don't even get what is happening
here
[Music]
i will build a great great wall
on our southern border and i will have
mexico okay
this stream's done
this stream's the streams are slowly all
winding down
[Music]
all right guys i don't think my ears can
take too much more of it so i think that
this is basically going to be um the end
of the stream
i appreciate everybody who joined me i
can't tell you how much i appreciate
everybody who signed up and supported
make sure you're following us on twitch
we're trying to get to 100 000 followers
make sure you're subscribed on youtube
we're trying to get to 1.5 million
subscribers we're going to be back very
soon there is a trump rally next
saturday which i will almost certainly
cover but even between now and then
we'll be covering press briefings and
all sorts of different things so uh
thanks to everybody for for joining me
i'm glad there was no riot at least as
far as we can tell uh good sirs and mams
we will see you all very very soon